In this section of our course, we will go over how to bring a metahuman into Unreal Engine
and go over some best practices for working with them in your project.
Let us begin by going over the download options and how to export a metahuman from Quixel Bridge
in order to add it to our Unreal Engine project.
In Unreal Engine with Quixel Bridge open, the first thing you will need to do is download your metahuman.
With the metahuman you wish to add to your project selected, select the quality you want to download.
In earlier versions of Unreal Engine 5.4, the options that were available were based on texture resolution quality.
We now have the option to select cinematic, which gives us full resolution textures with separate materials,
LODs focused on quality over performance, the highest fidelity animation blending, along with body and neck correctives enabled.
This also gives us full strand based hair on LOD 0 and the average file size will range between 2-3 GB.
For the high, medium and low optimized options, we will have compressed textures and optimized materials
with less instructions and baked textures, the LODs have been adjusted to improve performance,
and the settings that enable and disable correctives are based on LOD for more optimized animations.
We also have optimized hair grooms and the average file size is under 100 MB.
Once you have selected the quality you wish to download, it will take some time to process before you can download and export them to Unreal Engine.
If you wish to update a revised metahuman from the creator, Quixel Bridge will display an update button.
By updating this asset in Quixel Bridge, this does not mean the asset in the Unreal Engine project is updated.
You will need to re-download and re-export the metahuman to Unreal Engine.
Before you do so, as the asset will be overwritten, make sure to close all levels and sequences using the older version.
Then add it back into the project, save and restart.
Once the download of your metahuman has completed, on the bottom right of your selected metahuman in Quixel Bridge,
you can now click Add to export the metahuman.
Inside of your project, you will see a metahuman's folder, and inside of that folder,
navigate to the folder with the name of the metahuman that was added, and double click on the blueprint to open it up.
Once you do so, pop-up prompts will appear for missing plugins and project settings in the lower right corner.
It is required that these are enabled, so click on Enable Missing on each, and then restart the engine.
Once you restart the project, you can start working with your metahuman.
Our course already has all of the required plugins and project settings enabled.
Now, let's jump into Unreal Engine and start working with our metahuman.
Inside of Unreal Engine, let's begin by going to the metahuman's folder.
Inside of this folder is where you will find the metahuman you have exported from Bridge.
Let's open up the folder named Lena underscore CQ.
I've added CQ to reference that this was downloaded with the cinematic quality settings.
Over here, we can see Lena's blueprint.
Let's double click on this to open it.
Inside of the metahuman blueprint, you will see it has an event graph, a construction script, and a viewport.
And this is where we can see our metahuman components brought together.
Let's bring this closer to view.
On the left side, we can see all of the components that make up a metahuman.
You will notice that when you select a component, in the Details panel on the right,
the options that are unique to that asset will be displayed.
We can modify each component's properties, and once finished making adjustments,
you can go here to compile and save those changes.
Now, let's return to our main viewport.
To add a metahuman to a level, simply drag and drop the metahuman blueprint in here.
In the Details panel on the right, go to the Transform to zero out its position.
I'm going to delete this because we already have a metahuman in the level.
Now, if we select this metahuman in the Details panel on the right, all of the components will be visible.
You can select each component and have the option to adjust things such as what you want to set the LOD to in the level.
For some assets such as the skeletal meshes, it may be best to adjust those inside of the blueprint.
Now, before we move on, let's review what we've just covered.
We have just taken a look inside of the metahuman blueprint.
Metahumans are made up of several components, and when selecting a component,
the options that are unique to that asset will appear in the Details panel.
We can modify components and their properties, and once finished making adjustments, we can compile and save those changes.
To add a metahuman to a level, drag the blueprint into the level.
When you select a metahuman in a level, all of the components and their options will be accessible in the Details panel,
and you can make adjustments to each component from there.
Now, let's return to Unreal Engine and go over how we can apply animations.
Metahumans come with built-in body and face control rigs, and we can use these to create animations.
To do this, we will first create a level sequence.
We can go up here and select Add Level Sequence.
I will save this in our Course Topics folder, and now you can add a metahuman to Sequencer,
either by going to the Outliner, selecting it and dragging it in here,
or we can go here on the left, select the Add button, and then go here to Actor to Sequence, and select it from here.
By default, the body and face control rig will appear.
Let's go to Perspective and select Cam01Body in order to view it better.
If we look at the body controls, we can move some of these controls by rotating each individual joint.
I will change the gizmo to Rotate, and I have already disabled snapping.
For controls that allow you to only rotate individual joints, this is called Forward Kinematics or FK.
I will change the gizmo to Translate, and I have already disabled snapping.
If I select the foot control over here, I can move a hierarchy of joints, and this is called Inverse Kinematics or IK.
By default, the arms are set to FK and the legs are set to IK.
If we go into Sequencer and scroll up, and then go to the Global Control Track, here, this is where you can switch controls from FK and IK.
Now, let's take a look at the face control rig.
I'm going to scroll up here and collapse the body control rig.
Let's go to Perspective and select the camera labeled Cam02Face, which will make it easier to see all of the face controls.
There are over 200 controls for the face.
In order to move and adjust them, make sure the gizmo is set to Translate and it's set to Local Space, and also ensure that snapping is disabled.
Now, we can click on a control and use the slider to move it.
If you want to select multiple controls at the same time, select the first control and then hold down Shift and select Additional Controls.
To create a key, press the letter S, or you can create a key in the Animation Details panel over here on the right, or in Sequencer over here.
Let's move a few frames over and now move these controls and press the letter S to set a key.
If I script through this, we can see we just created an animation.
Now, let's see how to go about exporting this as an animation sequence.
I'm going to scroll up to the top and collapse the face control rig board.
I'm going to select the component for the face and right-click, and then select Bake to Animation Sequence.
You will be prompted to name your animation and direct it to a folder, and once you do so, it will export this as an animation sequence.
Now, before we continue, let's do a quick review of the steps we just completed.
To access the body and face control rig, add the metahuman to Sequencer, and by default, the body and face control rigs will appear.
The body control rig uses both FK and IK for moving controls.
FK stands for Forward Kinematics, which allow you to rotate individual joints.
IK stands for Inverse Kinematics, and allows you to move a hierarchy of joints.
To use the face control rig, select controls with the gizmo set to Translate in local space.
To create an animation with control rig, select the controls you wish to adjust and set keys for them by pressing the letter S,
or set keys in the Animation Details panel or inside of Sequencer.
To export an animation from Sequencer that has been created with control rig, right-click on the face or body component track in Sequencer,
and select Bake to Animation Sequence.
The control rigs are helpful in that they allow you to quickly pose and animate your metahuman.
Now, let's jump back into Unreal Engine and take a look at how we can apply existing body and facial animations to a metahuman.
In order to apply existing animations to a metahuman in Sequencer, begin by selecting the face control rig and the body control rig,
and then deleting them.
For the animations that we will apply, I am going to go over here and change the track length of the sequence to 600 frames.
I will use the N bracket down here to expand the sequence length and then go to the start of the sequence.
Let's apply an animation to the body first.
On the body track, go to the plus sign, then go to Animation in order to add an animation track.
Search for mh underscore sample body and select it.
Now, this is a body animation from the Sample Metahumans project.
We now have an animation applied to the body.
Let's repeat this for the face.
Go to the plus sign, then to Animation and search for mh sample face and then select it.
Let's go to Perspective and select cam3 face.
If we play the sequence, we can now see our metahuman come to life.
And this is how you apply existing animations to the metahuman face and body in Sequencer.
Now there may be instances where perhaps you want to adjust an existing animation.
To do this, you can bake the animation to control rig.
Select the body or face component whose animation you wish to adjust.
Then right click on the component and then go here and select Bake to control rig.
For the body, you would select metahuman control rig.
Now before we move on, let's review the steps we just completed.
We have just looked at how we can apply an existing animation sequence to a metahuman in Sequencer.
Begin by deleting the default control rig tracks, then use the plus sign on the body or face component to add an animation track.
If you want to adjust an existing animation, you can bake that animation to the control rig by right clicking on the face or body component
and selecting Bake to control rig.
All metahumans are performance capture ready using LiveLink, LiveLink face, metahuman animator and more.
We've only scratched the surface with what is possible with metahumans.
And we delve much deeper into the topics we have covered with the metahuman blueprints and animation course.
Now let's wrap up this introductory course with some final recommendations.
Thank you for watching.